how's it goin we are doing the next CV
for school thing that we've been going
through this is episode four my name is
Matt you're watching KOAT a Coriolis and
now that I said all that let's get going
okay so we left off last episode we had
finished three so now we're gonna go
straight to four write a program which
accepts a character and displays its
next character very good okay and why
I'm doing this just in case you don't
know the whole point of this is really
just to help new people learn C++ and
get through the basics because I can
often be the most challenging part I
found it's just getting started so
that's the whole intention of this
series if you're in that seat and want
to want to learn I'd recommend starting
from the beginning of this and picking
through these and given one you can't
okay so let's see we left off we had
done one two and three as we're all
working fine if you want to see those
check last episode but we're gonna go
ahead and start with number four here
and writer programmers have accepts a
character and displays its next
character so as you saw on the previous
episode characters are displayed by
their what am I trying to say here
they're an integer every character is
just an integer it has an ASCII code so
if we just go to the next ASCII code it
should go to the next character and we
can just do that we'll say enter a
character will show them next we all
right and we'll just do a C out I guess
we could just do it like this and that
way we can we just make an integer or a
character rather called
a thingy I want to call it
alright and then we'll just see in this
thingy so that way we ask for the
variable and then what we do next is we
just just go to the next thing it was
thingy plus plus seeing such a weird
word
and then we'll just spit it out here so
we will say next character is and then
notice output so if we press if we enter
a we should get beef we interview which
you can see and so on so let's get a new
line here that way we don't have a weird
consul but now it's noted that you don't
have to do this right here you could do
it in line right here but this actually
will probably say the current one and
then plus it up next
oddly enough so you would actually have
to do something like this if you really
wanted to increment in line because this
is a pre preprocessor so it'll go to the
next one before spitting it out so
that's a new thing that you know and
this will do it after so we can see the
difference here I'll do this one we'll
see we should get the same character
this should be wrong but I just want to
test it here do I have a make file yeah
I do
Oh beautiful okay so we'll just run make
here will show that excel press a and it
says the next character is a and just as
predicted it didn't work so if we put
these preprocessor things here and save
and recompile we should actually get it
to work kay X characters B so there you
go
and you'll if you really have this
question in a lab they might want you to
keep this variable the same and save the
next one or something so there's another
way of doing it I'll just show you real
quick little to say care next equals
thingy plus one and that should work too
but of course this has to be next so
there's multiple ways of doing this and
whatever is the cleanest and seems the
the best for you is probably the best
then there goes next character is B I
was easy enough let's try it with some
weird character and see what happens
like a capital Z and it says the next
character is bracket so in the ASCII
code the next next character after
capital Z is a bracket now you can test
this all you want or you can just go
look at ASCII chart and you can figure
it out like if we press the for
character we get the 5 character it's
the next one alright very good so that
that wasn't too hard let's go to the
next one 5 write a program
which accepts a day as an integer and
displays the total number years months
and days in it for example of an M user
inputs 856 days out there should be two
years four months and six days now we're
making some assumptions here such as
well we know how many days are in a year
it's 365 but months are a little
trickier we can't we'll just assume
every month is 30 days to make it simple
but some months or shorter so months was
longer so it kind of depends on where
you're starting you need more of a
proper date/time library to actually do
this accurately so we'll just yet we'll
assume each year is thirty and we kind
of did this problem in the first episode
with the dollars I think now is this
it's like this the exact same thing as
this you just subtract off the biggest
parts first and and and hold it okay so
that will go ahead and do that so we're
up to five here I don't know I think I'm
gonna move this over a little over this
over a little this doesn't matter but I
guess we'll leave it okay I just want
you guys to be able to see actually the
full line as I type of here I guess I
can collapse this over here okay so
let's go ahead and do this and I will
say years months and days since X number
of days ago I guess that'll work for a
little blurb and I'll just copy that
line with control D and I'll say and I'm
just going to say enter number of days
- cow spell that correctly and that way
it'll just prompt and there it goes
entered the wrong number
okay yeah every time it feels like every
time I try to end my line with the
second double quotes it just doubles
them off like this and it just it ruins
it for me okay well anyway that's an
editor problem there so we want a number
of days we need to store this variable
will say it will do it all integers
because that makes sense numb of days
and we'll just grab that variable
alright so there that'll get that and
then we just need to calculate it out
and get the the months so we can
actually just sit here and say yeah
we'll just keep it simple
we need years two years months days and
now we just need to calculate these
based on the number of days input so
we'll say if the number of days yeah
we'll do this the easy way check this
out we'll do a little flow of control
we'll get a little more advanced here
I'm just going to do a while and we'll
say wild number of days okay numb of
days we'll say wow it's greater than or
equal to 365 and you can probably guess
what we're gonna do next here we'll say
go years plus plus every time it goes
into this loop and then we will subtract
off the number of days so then we'll do
on of days minus equals 365 so we're go
ahead and subtract that year off and
then when it goes to the next loop if it
still has 365 or more at least it'll
toggle another year and strike it off
then when that's done we'll process the
months in a very similar way number of
days should be updated by here so it
should be less than 365 in any case and
we'll just do another well greater than
or equal to 30 or assuming a month is 30
days here so
had to get super complicated and
calculate February the case of February
we don't even know when this is starting
actually this is this is too vague a
thing and that's something you gotta use
to as a software developer is big
questions because if you ever get hired
and someone and someone that doesn't
know anything about programming wants
something they're gonna give you the
most vague crappy thing to do and you're
gonna be like well I guess I gotta
figure it all out on my own because they
don't know if the heck they're doing
that's why they hired me so there you go
it's job security don't worry about it
it's a good thing so yeah how you got to
figure out what they mean by by months
cuz cuz months is vague it really they
should have in parentheses or something
here that assume a month is thirty days
because we know a year we know what it
is but a month that's questionable
twenty to thirty one or we could just
make a random number generator that
generates something between 28 and 31
and and goes off of that and it's just
never the same and never accurate
totally because while the person who
gave you the thing to do was not precise
anyway so enough about that basically
we're just gonna say Museum in 30 days
and disregard all that so if the number
of days is greater than or equal to 30
we're gonna say well we're gonna plus up
the months and we're gonna subtract 30
off the number of days and since this is
a while loop then it's gonna continue
until number of days is less than 30 and
then we'll have just the days left and
whatever is left is the days so then
it's gonna equal the number of days no
need to do a subtraction loop on a bunch
of ones it's just going to be equal to
whatever is and then we can see out at
the end and say well I
how verbose I want to be I've obviously
just completely messed up this number of
days variable but I can kind of sort it
back out based on quick calculation or I
could just hold another variable and
keep the original one the same I know
it's a mouthful but it just depends how
you want to do this output because we
could say we could say X amount of days
like numb of days is is so many years
yeah so all sorts out a little better in
a second here the years is just gonna be
a number so it'll say however anyone
named it however many number of days is
this many years comma this many months
comma in this many days you know we
don't even need honestly now they think
about it just based on the way of doing
it I don't actually need this day
variable because whatever is left over
at the end here is just numb of days so
we got it we got a a few ways of doing
this I recommend doing whatever's
clearest there we go so that way we can
just completely get rid of this just
since we're updating that numb of days
variable anyway and that will save us a
tiny bit of memory which isn't a big
deal for one integer but it could add up
if you're doing a complicated mess of
things
so this num of days is going to be wrong
what we have to do is we have to do a
big calculation here to make this prop
the proper number of starting days so we
would say whatever the years is times
365 because that's how many days are in
a year and then we want to add to that
months times 30 and then we also want to
add to that just numb of days
so that shouldn't give us a proper spit
out of what's going on there and I'll go
ahead and just click surround the entire
thing right there in parentheses so this
should get us back to their original
number of days is this many years as
many months as many days and that should
give us the answer let's go ahead and
give that a test and it will just do
eight you know I'm gonna bring this down
well I want you guys to be able to see
the whole thing at once maybe maybe
that's important I guess about rate it
will break or kill some of these lines
here right there
and let's go over a little further here
there we go
so that's the whole thing we'll just do
a make and it's gonna run and say okay
another number of days to count let's
say 500 and see what it does and it says
500 maybe we should say days here days
is one years years so we could make a
little a little ternary operator here to
output the proper number of years
because one years is obviously bad
English and you don't want to do that so
what we could do here is actually
something a little tricky I'll go ahead
and show you this will do this is
actually kind of important for
formatting so ternary operator which we
learned and one of the previous episodes
so if years is greater than one you know
wait a second
well how do you say zero years you say
it with plural because you don't say
zero year you would say zero years
that's really really freaking awkward so
basically if years is not equal to one
is what we're gonna do then we say years
why English so wait a second now that
I'm thinking about this is just freaking
awkward so in English we use we we say
zero as plural it's been zero years it's
obviously not plural it's nothing but
zero year doesn't sound right anyway
okay that's a side ramp but what that's
just weird
so okay so it was not equal to one we're
gonna say years otherwise we're going to
say just year because one year and we
could do the same thing for months so
we'll go ahead and you know we'll go
ahead and do that so if months is not
equal to one
then we're going to say okay I'm just
going to break this up in multiple lines
at this point so I'm going to break
right at this here note that there's no
actual newline I just want to have each
set of this on a new line
you
and what are we doing wrong here I think
I need to surround this entire thing in
parentheses yes
okay yeah so apparently when you're
doing these in line like this you don't
surround the entire thing in parentheses
so it's not confused okay so if months
is not equal to one
we're going to say months comma
otherwise we're just going to say month
and we need a space up here comma and we
can get rid of this whole months there
and we do need to surround this whole
thing in parentheses but now this will
give us a proper output a number of days
we need to do the same thing to a number
of days is not equal to one English why
why you got to do this to us almost do
our starting practices here I'll go
ahead and prep her end one right there
but basically if number of days is not
equal to one
we're gonna say days plural otherwise
we're going to say day cuz it was just
one day we say day yeah and that's it
that should give us the correct answer
and a proper English sentence no matter
how we enter our numbers there we go
so another number of days to Kapler
shouldn't say one see what this does
it'll say one days Oh
I need a space here and Oh oh god I
didn't actually correct this so if this
is only one this dais is going to be
going to be wrong so we could correct
that whole thing by once again doing
another ternary operator here insane
well
yeah this I'm done I I'm sure you can
figure out how to correct that if you
want but I'm done I'm done with this
question I'm moving on a little
excellent here's here's this so if you
enter one it's just one day yeah you're
gonna get the wrong one but we could
make a little ternary operator and sort
that out too but we've done enough this
is taking too long let's let's do nine
hundred days and see how that goes
900 days is two years oh I forgot to
actually say months so my bad so I need
a months here and then I need to spit
out the word and same with the days so
if he caught that earlier Congrats
you're you're more skilled logic person
than I am
okay let's try that 900 again and we get
900 days is two years five months and I
guess we could have an end here and okay
thank you control dijo s there we go so
there's the answer there it's a man put
on cameras put a giant number and we'll
say oh that's a lot of years once in
seven days okay space there all right
well that's enough of that that's going
on the next one this is gonna be the
last one for now number six what is the
output of the following program okay so
we might not actually need to code for
this but we can test it with some code
okay so we're done with this whole day's
thing and as you can see that's how you
also do ternary operators right in line
to get the proper to just correct
English and stuff too so that's kind of
cool or correct whatever language you're
using you might not be so be using
English doesn't matter but the point is
formatting formatting is important and
you can assist your formatting in ways
like this
all right when's the output of the
following program and result equals four
plus five times six plus two now like I
explained an episode of two ago it this
doesn't follow the please excuse my dear
Aunt Sally rule for C++ so this is going
to go from left to right it's gonna do
four plus five which is nine let's go to
nine times six which is what 54 and then
plus two so this should be 56 yeah
listen this should be 56 let's go ahead
and click show the answer and see if 56
is correct no 36
wait why okay it is following the please
excuse my dear Aunt Sally rule because
this is 30 and we add four and add two
and we get 36
what did I misspeak of compilers changed
these days from when I originally
learned now I feel like I'm miss miss
guiding people let's just do this we
want a new line here since we're putting
it in the sea how they should have one
too but they don't care I guess if
you're returning this then obviously the
new new line but they're not returning
there see out in it so they should have
a new line there but they don't um yeah
I guess let's just go ahead and run this
and see what happens we get 36 so I was
wrong apparently it does follow the
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally rule
that's actually news to me what I
usually do is carefully separate them
out with parentheses to make them go in
the order I want so I guess I haven't
tested this in a really long time just
cuz I assumed it wouldn't be proper but
it is proper it does follow it to some
extent I don't know how far so take it
with a grain of salt I'd still recommend
using parentheses to sort it out the way
you want but yeah I seem to get left to
right so that's interesting
we don't really need six and okay so
this will be the same thing except it's
using a modulo which is basically a how
many are left
I guess modulo would happen before the
Plus just taking a guess here and based
on that it's going to be seven modulo 2
2 will go into 7 3 times and it'll have
one left over
so this is going to evaluate to 1 and
then a plus
so we should get a six here so cuz five
plus one and let's just spit that out
and see what we get
and we need a standard here and we need
a new line here otherwise it's gonna
look real crappy alright and let's just
see if we get an actual six we do okay
so it does the modulo before the plus
good to know does it do the modulo
before the times I don't know you can
test that all on your own if you want
but there you go if you don't know how
modular works
it wasn't really explained in any of
these labs directly yet but basically
it's how many are left over after a full
division so yeah seven modulo 2 how many
times is to go in this seven or how many
you're left over after dividing by two
so it would be it's the remainder
basically so that's standard division
stuff here so this would equal if you
were doing a division it would be 3
remainder of 1 so with a modulo it's
just a remainder of 1 is the answer and
there's just one hope that helps all
right well that's gonna do it for this
episode and the next one I'll continue
on and I'll try to hammer out the rest
of these and carefully explain
everything as I go thanks for watching
hope you all have a great day and let me
know if have any questions below if
you'd like to see any specific examples
or have any certain questions you want
me to try to answer I will do that I do
plan on going to leak code eventually
and working through some of those on
here so maybe after I get through all
these labs this is taking a little
longer than expected I thought it would
like fly through these in a few minutes
but stopping to explain and think about
things is taking a little longer and
it's kind of important like like when
given a question like that months one I
yeah it's I could quickly just assume
months is thirty but you know if a real
person we're asking me to do this I
would go straight to them and be like
what do you mean by months I don't want
you to I don't want you to doc my grade
or I don't want to mess up the program
because uh because I make some some
assumption so so what do you need here
four months do you want me to carefully
calculate
which month it would be based on how
long ago does you know you can do that
all right well once again I'm out peace
out guys see in the next episode